aus Rostock ist uns Professor Carlo
marsalla von der Universität der
Bundeswehr in München zugeschaltet guten
Abend Herr Masala schönen guten Abend
Frau wie schätzt sie denn im Moment die
militärische Lage ein soweit man das von
außen kann insgesamt es ist extrem
schwierig sie momentan von außen
einzuschätzen was man sagen kann ist
dass die Ukraine jetzt wieder zurück ist
letzten Endes auf dem Versuch so viel
russische Logistik wie möglich zu
zerstören um dann Truppen vom von der
Versorgung abzuschneiden man versucht
die Krim zu isolieren die ja ein
wichtiger sozusagen logistischer
Schwerpunkt ist für die Versorgung der
Truppen im Süden was die
Truppenbewegungen selber anbelangt so
ist gestern erfolgreich zum ersten Mal
den japper in der Nähe von überschritten
worden wir wissen allerdings nicht ob
die ein bisschen Ukraine gelungen ist
dort ein Brückenkopf zu errichten es
gibt Kämpfe bei bachmut die russischen
Truppen vor allen Dingen im im Osten ähm
gehen zu Gegenangriffen über teilweise
auch erfolgreich verdrängen die Ukraine
zurück also es ist letzten Endes ein
sehr verworrendes Bild aber ich glaube
sozusagen die große Strategie der
Ukraine momentan ist es wieder sich
verstärkt auf nachschubbewege und
Logistik der russischen Armee zu
konzentrieren um die Truppen von
Nachschub und Logistik abzuschneiden und
dann möglicherweise eine Möglichkeit
eine Chance zu haben für entscheidendere
Angriffe aber so schnelle Vorstöße und
Geländegewinne wie wir sie im letzten
Herbst noch gesehen haben von Seiten der
Ukraine die gibt es im Moment ja nicht
nein das war auch von vornherein
unrealistisch das anzunehmen weil die
Russische Föderation hatte vier fünf
Monate Zeit ihre Verteidigungsstellungen
wirklich intensivst auszubauen also
jeder der geglaubt hat dass es so
aussehen würde wie im September des
letzten Jahres der lag von vornherein
falsch und ich glaube man sollte auch
nicht zu sehr auf die Frage von
Territorium gegenwärtig schauen sondern
das zentrale ist ich schaffen es die
Ukraine die russischen Truppen sozusagen
in die Länge zu ziehen dadurch
Schwachstellen zu erzeugen schaffen sie
es die Logistik zu zerstören um dann
möglicherweise entscheidende Angriffe
durchzuführen hier ist momentan eher
Geduld angesagt als dieses beständige
schauen wer hat wie viel 100 Meter
gerade gestern eingenommen du Ukrainer
sagen auch während ihr doch darüber
debattiert habt ob er uns Panzer schickt
oder nicht haben dann die Russen halt
großes Gelände vermiet nun gibt es ja
wieder eine Debatte also die Ukraine
hätte sehr gerne mehr von den
Marschflugkörpern die von Großbritannien
und Frankreich auch schon geliefert
wurden in Deutschland hat ein ähnliches
System Taurus aber da ist die
Bundesregierung bisher sehr zögerlich
was ist da der Hintergrund
ich glaube der Hintergrund ist der
gleiche den wir letztes Jahr hatten bei
der Frage der Panzerlieferungen die
Bundesregierung ist deshalb zögerlich
weil die Amerikaner ihrerseits diese
Kurzstrecken Raketen mit längerer
Reichweite also die sogenannten Attacke
Mass bislang noch nicht liefern und ich
glaube wenn der Knoten in den USA
platzen sollte dann wird auch die
Bundesregierung Taurus liefern es war ja
interessant das Boris Pistorius in
diesem zitierten Interview von vor zwei
Tagen gesagt hat die Zeit für die
Entscheidung sei noch nicht reifen das
heißt die Bundesregierung hält sich
diese Frage offen und das kann
eigentlich nur daran liegen dass sie wie
bei der panzerfrage sich hier eng mit
den USA koordiniert und wenn die USA
sich entscheiden sollten attack MS zu
liefern dann gehe ich davon aus dass die
Bundesregierung sich auch für die
Lieferung von Taurus entscheiden wird
ein Argument von von Kritikern angeführt
warum man das nicht tun sollte ist dass
sie eben über mehrere hundert Kilometer
reichen und damit ja auch russische
Territorium für die Ukraine erreichbar
wäre
theoretisch ist das Argument richtig
praktisch glaube ich ist es irrelevant
aus dem einfachen Grunde weil mit der
Storm Shadow mit der Skype also der
französischen den französischen
Marschflugkörper verfügt die Ukraine
bereits über Systeme mit denen sie
russische Territorium erreichen kann sie
tut es nicht weil sie den beiden
Regierungen die geliefert haben
versprochen hat dies nicht zu tun und
das gleiche würde sie auch der
Bundesregierung versprechen und
gleichzeitig weiß die Ukraine in dem
Moment in dem sie Taurus einsetzt um z.B
russische Territorium anzugreifen für
die die komplette westliche
Unterstützung wie ein Kartenhaus in sich
zusammenfallen weil die Ukraine sich an
eine Vereinbarung dann nicht hält also
warum sollte KEF dieses Risiko eingehen
bedeutet aber auch dass die Russen quasi
aus ja sicherer Entfernung vom eigenen
Territorium aus Raketen und alles andere
mögliche andere schicken und das dort
ihre Stellungen aber eigentlich sicher
sind weil die Ukraine darf ja nicht und
kann auch nicht das ist in der Tat das
entscheidende Problem also dadurch dass
die ich sag jetzt mal die die Ukraine
unterstützen den Staaten alle Angst
davor haben dass ihre Waffen bei
Angriffen auf auf russisches Territorium
eingesetzt werden gibt man natürlich der
Russischen Föderation einen Vorteil wenn
man jetzt das Kriegsvölkerrecht sich
anschaut dann ist es völlig legitim zum
Beispiel russische Bomber die im
russischen Luftraum sind und von dort
Marschflugkörper in die Ukraine
abschießen auch im russischen Luftraum
zu zerstören aber das ist sozusagen die
Horrorvorstellung der westlichen
Regierungen weil man dann die berühmte
Eskalation befürchtet die bis heute
nicht eingetreten ist aber die halt
sozusagen wie ein damoklestschwert über
den den Entscheidungen der meisten
westlichen Regierungen schwebt danke für
das Gespräch ich danke Ihnen